One of the fundamental objects
in R is a vector, which is
just a term to mean a single
set of values in
a particular order.
We can create a simple vector
in R using the concatenate
function, which is the function
represented by a
lowercase c.
Inside the parentheses, we put
values or other vectors
separated by commas, and these
will be stuck together to
create a new vector.
When we print the vector, R
simply prints the values one
after another.
You might wonder--
what happens if there are so
many values in the vector that
it hits the end of the line?
Well, the values drop to the
next line, just like the text
would if you were writing
a paragraph.
Notice that there's also a
little extra information in
the first and second lines.
In the first line, we have a
number 1 in brackets, and on
the second line, we have a
number 10 in brackets.
In each case, these correspond
to how far R is into the
vector at the start
of each line.
For example, the 10 indicates
the first element on the
second line is the 10th
element of the vector.
The 1 in the brackets at the
start of the output indicates
that this line was the start
of the printed vector.
This brings up a subtle point.
Looking back on our earlier
output, we can see the bracket
1 in each output.
While each earlier output looked
like a scalar, that is,
a standalone number, each of
these is really a vector with
a single value.
In R, a vector of length 1 is
equivalent to a scalar.
For those vectors with length
greater than 1, it is common
for us to want to access
a specific element.
Let's call our longer vector
v. If you wanted to look at
just the first element of v,
we use brackets with a 1.
Or if we wanted the third
value, we could
use a 3 in the brackets.
We can also request several
values at once.
To do so, we create a vector
that indicates the positions
of the values we
want returned.
Then we put this vector
into the brackets.
So let's suppose we
want to look at
the first three values.
We start by creating
a vector 1, 2, 3.
Here I've done that using the
special notation 1:3, which
produces a vector with
values 1, 2, 3.
I'll save this vector into a
variable called look.at, and
then I'll use look.at inside
the brackets to get at the
first three values of v.
There are three more functions
worth remembering when it
comes to vectors--
length, head, and tail.
The length function indicates
the number of
elements in a vector.
The head function returns
the first six
observations in the vector.
And the tail function returns
the last six observations in
the vector.
Here's a v printed out
for comparison.
Also, if we want, we can specify
a second argument in
the head or tail functions.
This second argument
says how many
observations we want to see.
For example, here I'll specify
that I want to see just the
last three values of v using
the tail function with 3 as
the second argument.
In the next video,
we'll work with
character and Boolean vectors.